a land of stone and Sky sage and pine
vast ancient and for the people who have
lived here for a thousand Generations
this is Holy Land
this is a very sacred Place uh place of
our beginning that mountain right back
here is very significant to us in our
medicine now much of this land
surrounding the Grand Canyon will be
preserved permanently off limits to
mining Drilling and other development
today I'm proud to use my sergeant of
Antiquities Act to protect one almost
one million Acres of public land around
Grand Canyon National Park as a new
National Monument
President Joe Biden designated four
thousand square kilometers as a National
Monument a power that presidents wield
without Congressional approval
Native American leaders pressed for
years to protect ancestral lands outside
their reservation boundaries
the tribes are particularly concerned
about uranium mining which they believe
would contaminate their drinking water
and flow into the Colorado River
mining interests denounced Biden's
action they say it kills jobs and
increases U.S Reliance on foreign
sources of uranium including Russia
there are political calculations that
work also Biden barely beat Donald Trump
here in Arizona in 2020 Native American
voters were crucial to that Victory and
Biden wants to keep their support in
next year's election
Biden noted the long struggle by native
people against uranium extraction
I fought for decades to be able to
return to these lands to protect these
lands from Mining and development
for Havasupai Elder Diana White Dove
euquala the new monument honors those
who fought for it but didn't live to see
this day for them
I hold my hands up high
courage
to be able to speak instead
for this place
a sacred land now finally preserved
Rob Reynolds Al Jazeera Red Butte
Arizona
foreign